45 seconds of logos even in a slightly
apocalyptic future camp Logan fine
better work than being a limo driver it
would have been much less action but the
movie right before this one about how we
got to this point it sure be interesting
I know Logan is an old drunken trail of
his former self but under what
circumstances did he say ma'am I need to
perk my limo on the side of the road
under all these super bright billboards
and take a nap well yes he's old and
busted now and weaker but still how many
times do we need to see the random
criminal outfit underestimates
Wolverines abilities and ends up dead
because of it routine you cannot put on
a white shirt over fresh bloody wounds
and expect to maintain said shirts
whiteness hey Clyde it's thanks for the
date certainty futuristic talk radio
buffoon pretty sure even when you're a
limo driver you're not supposed to get
drunk in full view of the funeral party
just saying also I'm beginning to think
it's not officially a comic book movie
unless one of the heroes is brooding
next to a cemetery at least one shot I
knew it was you how did she know it was
him he did nothing over enlight here
don't wait for me this is but one of
many times Wolverine will drop the
f-bomb just because he can fact it gets
super distracting as this movie goes
along this crazy lady no Logan took
someone to a funeral today and where the
cemetery was this guy I just knew Logan
would be at this hospital today to pick
up some drugs from his nurse dealer a
drug deal that apparently takes place
out in the open this guy's not a
terminator or a Bucky Barnes but he does
have a metal hand you should feel on
this about I guess since the wheel lugs
they found belong to a 24 Chrysler and
tell the gang trying to steal the
hubcaps that was a chrome plated lugs
triple plating flakes huh basically
meaning that they didn't succeed in
removing any for the cops to find I'm
not looking to you really I'm looking
for someone
looking for you how would this guy know
Gabriela is looking for Wolverine and if
he knows that how has he not found her
yet also he's looking for Laura because
the company he works for needs to get
her back and cover it up but since all
the other mutants escaped isn't the
Kitty bride out of the bag at this point
I don't they have the technology to
create more mutants seems like a waste
of resources to go find a child
Wolverine when you could just make one
in the lab kind of Logan to carry
Professor X to his bed for some rest and
I'd be calmed by this imagery if he
wasn't also leading the wheelchair so
far away from the bed is to render
Charles immobile until further human
assistance arrives
all right even Professor X is saying we
are all having a good time no news Stan
hmm that seems like the exact
circumstances of the movie children of
mint which made about 15% of what this
movie made to bad children a man didn't
have a Wolverine character so more
people could have seen it that bad guy
earlier in the lumo straight-up told
Logan he knew about his keeping
Professor X down here in Mexico so why
did Logan promptly take zero security
precautions upon arriving here busted
ass Wolverine can't even get all his
claws out without assistance what come
just now realizing it's the most brutal
IDI joke ever got damn some movie
footage taken from the unaired Wolverine
episode of the acclaimed show
intervention or the puss you know wiping
away from your knuckles or the blood I
wash from your clothes or the fresh
wounds in your chest this guy started
out like a genuine character who cares
but now I see it's just an exposition
machine the film's first script meeting
a producer asked we have an R rating so
what should we do
immediately tad jumped up and wrote
boobs on the whiteboard and everyone
laughed and then the Laughing got
violent out of control and everyone
started high-fiving everyone else in the
face and everyone got bludgeoned to
death later the Jimmy John's guy arrived
and noticed the dead bodies and the
whiteboard and finished writing the
scene and the rest of the screenplay and
still delivered all the sandwiches on
time look guys this article is some
bullsh gabriella could have easily
bought or rented a car that pearce
didn't recognize and made the North
Dakota trip herself or what oh we missed
our chance to cross because the Canadian
border closes for weeks at a time it
only takes illegal immigrants on an
appointment basis so gabrielle is dead
but what was it that finally led piers
here did he go through the yellow pages
and call every single motel asking about
a mom and her daughter until he got the
one where the manager was like yes I
know who you're talking about the little
girls always picked it up in the parking
lot murder them promptly pleased these
guys killed Gabriella but didn't search
the room for her phone what a bunch of
amateurs
also good thing Logan was curious of the
whereabouts of her phone
could think a brayla stuck it in a
drawer and knew Logan would go searching
forward since it contains the video
evidence germane to the plot
when did Logan open up the trunk to his
limo he drove in immediately started
walking into the shelter and then the
trunk magically opened I guess lower
could have done it somehow well I opened
the trunk and immediately hide again
especially since we find out she's a
ridiculously badass mini Wolverine also
she stowed away in his little trunk fine
he didn't hear her get in or anything
I'm a long drive to Mexico fine but a
girl that eight didn't need food or a
restroom anywhere along the journey long
after making the threat villain guy
finally shows up to Logan's cueball
compound in Mexico and of course he's in
a black SUV what he wakes up before I
get that now he's double unconscious at
twice the recovery time it's on a mutant
yes she is
what's her gift Charles eating pipe
throwing this premature questioning of
Laura's powers is brought to you by the
wholesome goodness of Kellogg's
cornflakes also Jesus he's known and
been around her what ten minutes why is
he so certain she's not a mutant as
Charles previously declared dozens of
other children to be the one he was
predicting only to be wrong thereby
giving Wolverine a reason for this
instant doubt okay a couple things here
there's just no way this asshole even if
he was faking could have gotten up got
into the truck open the door and
retrieve that gun this fast without
being hurt also and perhaps more
importantly this shot of the albino
walking back to the truck proves these
background trucks here are some utter
and complete fictional bull unless
they're traveling at 350 miles an hour
also also Pierce's man just happened to
show up right at the moment when Caliban
threw his body out into the open and
just when Pierce regained consciousness
fantastic timing why would you think
ahead enough to have this camera and
monitor but not have anything further
out from the property is an early
warning device regarding unwanted
visitors let's be clear he's watching
all this go down on the monitor but it
doesn't stop eating her cereal and act
until her own life it's threatening yes
self-preservation is strong especially
with kids but the way this plays out
suggests she has zero heart and is fine
munching on cornflakes while Wolverine
gets the kicked out of him and yet she
saves the day here in a few minutes but
that doesn't make this moment any less
cold-blooded there to capture this girl
but do nothing for several seconds after
she walks outside I guess because she's
carrying a head but whatever these guys
are experts at missing then why bring a
whole bunch of gun-toting henchmen out
here then
here's told this guy to stop shooting
because she heals but the director of
the film wants this action scene to seem
more exciting so shooting girl your
heart out these assholes don't shoot the
tires and for some reason never thought
to slash the tires in the first place
racing to beat a train to avoid capture
and only barely making a cliche okay so
Logan found this phone in the motel room
where Gabriela got murdered but there
are two things that bother me about him
watching this video first the phone
apparently has no auto lock when lost
Gabriela went to her settings to prevent
the auto lock second even if she did set
it this way the battery life on the
phone was at 57% when Logan found it
meaning it survived an entire trip to
Mexico and countless more hours being
constantly on 3rd what exactly told
Logan to go back to her phone and find
videos on it this top-secret illegal
research facility sure has no one
monitoring to make sure employees don't
videotape the harsh conditions inside
here she is filming a secret green shot
that's so close at angles she's
basically this facility's documentarian
making soldiers but perhaps more
importantly they're letting me film
wherever the goddamn well please it's
like I'm not even here I don't even know
why I was trying to be stealthy about it
earlier also movie steals the flashback
from Captain America's Civil War
Logan helping Charles P is a scene I
could have gone the rest of my life
without seeing it not have been happy
not okay
hilarious moment but still nanoseconds
away from the being filleted this is
basically comic timing ex machina here
asshole gabriella decides that her
documentary is more important than
saving this kid's life I read about a
place north and on that vague statement
the entirety of this movie's plot will
hinge she read about it thank God it's
actually real she'd risk kids lives on
that also did Gabriella have access to
premium editing software she's able to
use the audio from her testimonial and
lay it on top of all the other footage
she's using and she could have had much
time to do this and she recorded her
testimonial in the motel room where she
later died if you're watching this it
means I'm dead cliche also geez wouldn't
all this video evidence have made Logan
more inclined to help her earlier movie
decides you can drive from Mexico to
Oklahoma City without any us cops
noticing all the bullet holes and road
rage damage to your car and pulling you
over
Logan shows up in a limo full of bullet
holes and smash glass and a guy who
looks a lot like Professor X is about to
be wheeled through casino and nobody
freakin notices that reports it if
Professor X is being called a weapon of
mass destruction then certainly he's
famous enough to
some recognition Christ I know he was a
drunk but they just got here and he's
already found that many bottles this is
a huge hotel room for folks trying to
lay low and simply get to Canada they
sure did splurge on the hotel room
budget after ridiculing these comics
earlier today Logan apparently still
took some with him to get the car
swapped and thank holy Moses he did
since that's how he learns about Eden
being fictional these two Rando villain
thugs are so obvious Logan spots them
immediately and it can't help but wonder
if it was the all-black attire the
sunglasses or the earpieces that gave
them away if they'd been dressed in
Hawaiian shirts and khaki is would they
blend it in it's shocking how much Logan
and Jason Bourne have in common actually
if Charles is strong and imbalanced
enough to cause this sort of thing why
it's Logan the only individual just
unfazed enough to walk and push elevator
buttons and he's got healing powers and
indestructible metal on his skeleton he
has zero mind powers whatsoever though
this movie is named after him and
perhaps that's enough
[Music]
hell yeah this scene and even though all
that was caught on camera and they were
super lots of stories up they will still
get out before some SWAT invasion of
this lobby
I guess you prefer me pharmaceutically
that's literally you with or without
medication this movie accurately
predicts the near future of automated
semi trucks but trucks sins by going too
far overboard to draw attention to it
because some stupid auto truck decides
to change lanes for no reason this movie
finds a 20-minute detour where Logan and
crew or essentially responsible for a
chain of events leading to the killing
of an innocent family
Logan is totally right of course but
ultimately to science that placing an
innocent family in danger is okay
because it would be rude not to help
them and go to their house for dinner
and spend the night well the government
funded hate squad goes at least know how
to find a good sunset to pose in front
of the aluminum hotels from it's not
even that nice according to the clock at
7:30 the nearest motel is two hours away
which means it will be the super late
hour of 9:30 by the time they get there
so I totally agree with their decision
to stay at this house since anything
past 9:00 leads to sleep deprivation and
Mad Max fury road conditions Charles
convinces Logan to stay at this house
because of the lack of sleep but why
can't here in Lawrence sleep in the car
Nate really loves horses and drawing
pictures of horses and generally all
things horse in fact this is an orgy of
evidence that this kid loves him some
horses but don't pigeonhole him he's
really into deathcore bands and Abraham
Lincoln to evil corporal
bent on creating children warriors
wasn't all bad they took fun group
photos and probably had beat the day
sometimes this entire scene
unfortunately Telegraph's that this
person isn't really Logan he's always
too far to the edge of the screen or
shrouded in shadow and it's evil clone
Logan who looks very much like Rio loca
so they could have been way less coy
with shots like this if they wanted to
fool us imagine if you saw Logan here
with enough light to see features on his
face and you weren't triggered by the
camerawork that something was amiss and
then you see someone you legit think is
Logan stabbed Charles that would rule
also I'm wondering why the x24 allows
Charles to tell this entire story before
killing him he's got a flare for the
dramatic there's some thinking killing
machine this was this moment almost
makes me forget how stupid it was to
stay here the x24 a ball of white-hot
rage decides against trying to kill his
less evil twin I was already bothered at
how he basically ignore Logan because he
didn't ignore anyone else in this house
thus far why does he have to walk all
slow like a terminator
how is he not programmed with any time
is of the essence software is it just
trying to be menacing flanked what
farmers the ones that x24 already killed
they're all dead dude makes me think
this shot was originally intended to
come slightly earlier in the scene
before x24 does all his carnage but
somehow I ended up back here later in
the scene where it doesn't make any
sense
also this gate allows this kind of armed
access and grenades just happen to be an
arm's length away
Caliban gives sufficient warning to
Pierce before blowing himself in the
struck up you know it's a Marvel movie
when you see the main hero fighting
against a stronger a bastardization of
himself
[Music]
okay this films action is brutal and
excellent and worth us in on is this guy
still alive he was stabbed in the chest
and thrown down some stairs bad guys
once again leave Logan's lone mode of
transportation completely intact before
doing their evil water probably has the
strength to carry Wolverine and maybe
has the ability to steal a truck how did
she drive it did she use an umbrella and
cane to reach the gas and brake pedals I
guess lowers world is like Star Wars
where people speak two different
languages to each other and understand
everything there's a two-day drive wait
you were in Oklahoma City having come
from Mexico you traveled north from
there found the farm family to help kill
then passed out the next day while
driving and the girl drove you to a tiny
town doctor so you're probably in Kansas
maybe even Nebraska my point is that
it's only a two-day drive from North
Dakota if you go by bicycle Wow his
shoulder neck and back are all
remarkably burnfree after this Jesus
Christ also those numbers are on the
manila envelope lower showed Logan and
are even in the fucking Eden storyline
comic book if it's a secret location how
many places did they need to leave the
number so the Lord could find it it
basically wrote these numbers on
everything Laura had in her possession
it's probably sewn in the inside of her
sock and tattooed on her bicep if they
just left it in the comic book and sent
that with lower then no evil people
would have been able to stumble on the
handwritten version on the photo to show
up in the finale no were you just
speaking Spanish out of spite I'm
guessing Laura's driving this car
they're using the toys from Toy Story 2
or the fish from finding Dory dude she
just kept it steady for what looks like
a couple hundred feet worth of cranking
and you say this just as the gurney
reaches the top are you the resident
asshole but you have a Apple in your
pocket right now this movie suddenly got
all hook on my ass
bangarang they could have called this
movie Logan Logan waking up a bunch and
wow that's a title for marketing
purposes it would be an accurate one
Yeah right what's called Van Helsing you
know it's the adamantium bullet I
intended to kill myself with which will
tie a nice little irony bow on this
movie when it's used to kill my evil
clone x24 duh hey this little girl she
kills this role she's so awesome I'll
take off yet another sin okay this is a
cool shot but this is the first time in
the entire movie the bad guys have used
drones why wouldn't they have surveilled
the farmhouse by drone earlier over the
original Mexican compound Logan called
home also why doesn't this drone look
cooler
in 2029 people this looks like a drone
from regular old 2016 because actually
scissoring also prank shaving and said
prank shaving was all just for this
cheeky comic book nod of a facial hair
look when these kids were escaping from
transition they either took monopoly and
risk before they left or they had time
to go to a store and either buy or steal
those games that happens to people I
care about
maybe it's true but it's also the most
overused trick for superheroes on film
to push people away to create emotional
conflict so forgive me if I am unmoved
it's been a full day since that
government drone flew over this compound
and that is just way too long they
should have attacked by lunchtime but
they're waiting until tomorrow for
reasons unexplained cool ominous drone
shot though bro
luckily Logan woke up in time to see
these drones the convoy of bad guys and
the ability to insert himself into the
finale I liked how after seeing the
obviously evil drones Logan still feels
the need to use the tourist goggles to
make sure the kids are actually in
danger I mean how much rescue time did
he lose with this Logan's Run say don't
these kids have powers okay but why are
there Canadian troops up there ready to
bust a cap the border seems pretty
ceremonial in this society and this is a
remote North Dakotan mountain range
where they are crossing so I doubt
there's any official border crossing
anyway but even if there were you have
an army and you have an X 24 and you're
chasing state secrets about genetically
modified super soldiers surely you would
just keep chasing them into Canada until
you were they were dead right you make
the border sound like a force field
these guys stop to watch the dirt
levitation Joe instead of just shooting
this chick
Logan movie finally gives Wolverine fans
something they've been wanting for eight
movies buzzer Kermode and it's looking
awesome this WWE want to be soldier guys
somehow found that green liquid Logan
took earlier he had the foresight to
think gee maybe a super mutant is
chasing us from behind leaving backpacks
and evidence in his wake on his way to
killing us all I should go investigate
the woods way behind where everyone else
in this movie currently is sure they
have Loras around it but why am they
figured out a better way to container
yet they're still pointing guns at her
which they know don't work and they
still haven't figured out some sort of
super strong silly putty kind of
bullshit that keeps the Hulk and the
flash up it though was not a mutant kind
it's a control it Xander decides it's
time to mana long because that's how
these assholes always end up dying
I will never get tired of her kicking
ass and screaming never kind of wish I
knew when all these kids powers were
before they got to this point I guess
somebody has the power to control plants
and I guess they're called
Arbor man or Arbor man or something this
kid is using some sort of force field or
blurry power and the others appear to be
doing stuff that we never learn about
that looks great null but anyone who
knows anything about x24 is going to
know that this is being worthless can't
these kids surround x24 and use their
undefined powers to kill him so this is
a touching moment man the movie can be
praised for actually killing big
characters during it but as much as I
love Laura turning this cross to make it
look like an X couldn't they have taken
him across the border and buried him in
Canada his place of birth I mean the guy
gets buried 500 feet away from his home
country and I'm supposed to be moved you
drag him into a stolen truck lower you
have the ability you're gonna give me a
key see car and some money for gas are
you gonna wake up in the hospital trust
me I know how these things play out oh
because you're from the future no
because of these you're gonna have a big
vegetable patch we're gonna have a
rabbit up and down and the flavell at
about an alpha Ford the rabbit
the swing-away and narrow
[Music]
now
swinging away the Indian Air Force drone
solar cells to power an entire farm
take biltong
laughs which logan language and
[Music]
she got me on the counter wasn't me
[Applause]